kommen wir nun nach brandenburg zwei
männerleichen in wittenberge
die polizei regelt alles ab beginnt ihre
ermittlungen und dann plötzlich gibt es
ein feuer eine etage drüber genau über
der wohnung in der die leichen lägen ein
wohnhaus in wittenberge brandenburg
es sind zwei tote rumänen dort von einem
freund gefunden
aufgrund der gesamtumstände übernommen
während die ermittler vor ort sind und
ihre arbeit nachgehen bricht ein
stockwerk höher plötzlich ein feuer aus
wie konnte es dazu kommen
zwei männer hatten sich offenbar der
polizei gegenüber als hausbewohner
ausgegeben offenbar haben sie das feuer
gelegt die ausgebrannte wohnung sie war
leer
nachbarn beobachteten wie die männer in
der wohnung ein und aus gingen die
männer wurden wenig später gefasst
und jetzt schalten wir zu unserem
reporter til biermann erklärungs die
sind wirklich seltsam fall ja es war so
dass die beiden rumänen am montag
eigentlich nach einer zweiwöchigen
quarantäne zeit kroner quarantänezeit
zur arbeit erscheinen sollten bei einem
fleischverarbeitungsbetrieb in 13
kilometer entfernten perleberg sie kamen
nicht zur arbeit
so war es dann dass ein arbeitskollege
von denen nachschaute im vierten stock
dieses hauses hinter mir und ich zeigt
dass mal dieses haus und er fand dann im
vierten stock wo jetzt die fenster auf
kipp sind wahrscheinlich wegen der große
wicklung zwei leichen ein die die die
hat eine stichverletzung einer saß in
der küche einer lag im schlafzimmer und
dann war es so dass der natürlich nur
die polizei rief die die machten dort
die tatortarbeit und dann kam halt gegen
es war gegen mittag dann kam gegen 19
uhr ein weiterer bewohner aus dem
fünften stock direkt darüber und sagt er
müsste mal kurz in seine wohnung konnte
sich halt auch ausweisen
mit
halt mit meldebestätigung dass da auch
wirklich wohnt polizei dachte sich
nichts dabei und dann plötzlich brach
dieses feuer aus was jetzt sehr
merkwürdig ist dass die polizei sagt
dass beide sachverhalte nichts
miteinander zu tun hätten
das wäre ja schon also eine merkwürdige
aktion wenn die polizei vor der tür
steht seine eigene wohnung anzuzünden
aber die ermittlungen dauern an aber
teil nochmal eine nachfrage kann man
denn da in diesem fall von polizei
versagen sprechen so wie ich das
verstanden habe nicht weil es ist ja so
dass diese dieser mann der dort kam sich
ausweisen konnte und ich glaube es ist
gang und gäbe bei der polizei leute auch
in gefahrengebiete und so weiter zu
lassen ist ja auch bei demonstrationen
sowie etwas abgesperrt ist in der regel
wenn man nachweisen kann dass man dort
wo und lassen die 1 durch dass der jetzt
dann oben seine wohnung seine eigene
wohnung angezündet während die polizei
vor der tür steht davon konnten die
wahrscheinlich nicht ausgehen weshalb
verwunderlich ist dass sie jetzt schon
sagen ziemlicher sicherheit dass es
nichts mit dem fall zu tun hat wer weiß
was bei diesem mann in den kopf vorging
der dass eine eigene wohnung anzündete
wer weiß dass in seiner wohnung lagerte
aber ja das ist alles noch das sind
jetzt spekulationen tatsächlich ich bin
gespannt was dabei rauskommt das sind
wir auch tb man herzlichen dank nach
wittenberge